you've made the decision
to come out why is now the right time
it's been
such a long time of lying um and i've
just processed and processed every day
of just about how i want to do it when i
want to do it and i think now it's just
the right time to do it you know i feel
like i'm ready to tell people about my
story i want people to know the real me
and lying all the times isn't what i
wanted to do and it has been a struggle
but now i just do feel like i'm ready to
be myself be free and just be confident
with it all talk us through your journey
when did you realize you were gay and
what impact has that had on your
football i can't really put a date on it
but i'd say maybe five or six you know
it has been quite a while at that age
you don't really think of football and
being game doesn't mix um so all the way
through my life i was like yeah it's
fine you'll get a girlfriend when you're
older and you'll change and
it'll be fine and then as you do get
older you realize you just can't and
it's just something that you won't be
able to do so i've had girlfriends in
the past to try and make all my mates
think that i'm straight and it was just
a massive cover-up so it has been a
struggle and then in school everyone
else used to ask me you sure you're not
gay and it was like no i'm not because i
wasn't ready but just don't want to lie
anymore did you feel as though you might
need to hide who you are to become a
professional footballer yeah i think so
obviously because there's no one out
felt like i do need to hide it and
wait until i've retired to maybe come
out but i just knew that that was just
such a long
time of just lying and
not being able to have what i want has
it impacted on your mental health at all
yeah it did impact my mental health but
you know i just came across that just
because i knew that what i wanted then
it was just a short period of time of
just over thinking and stress and
just a lot that came to my mind at once
but now you know it's just all gone and
i'm just confident and happy to be
myself finally how important have your
family been
through this was it a huge sense of
relief when you told your family yeah
definitely my mum my sister obviously i
lived with them and they were like yeah
we already knew so they already have the
idea of it and then when we told my
whole family you know i was quite scared
um with like the older generation just
because i didn't know how they would
react but everyone's been so supportive
i've had messages here and everywhere
just saying you know we're proud and
we're supportive so yeah it's been it's
been amazing the day i told my mom my
sister the day after we played atkinson
and i scored four so it just shows how
much of a weight off the shoulders it
was and just a massive relief how much
support have you had from the club
during this process it's been absolutely
amazing you know the club were the first
people i told
and because that was the environment i'm
in every day and i feel safe and then my
teammates and they've all been so
supportive about it and you know
everyone's had their back i had my back
and you know they've all been asking
questions i've all been intrigued about
what actually happened so you know it's
been amazing and it's just the best
thing i could have asked for you've told
some of your teammates yeah how did they
react everyone was just like
you know kind of shocked in a way
because people were saying why didn't
you tell us earlier which is quite a
good thing it just shows that they they
can you know the captain and he was one
of the main people i told him he was
just asking loads of questions about and
he was like i'm just so proud of you and
you know i like when people ask
questions if i keep asking more you know
i just want to get it all out and just
people to hear my story everyone's just
been so supportive and so proud of me
and you know it just
shows that what a bond we have as a team
and you know everyone is just like a
family to each other did that reaction
surprise you i'm guessing you had a few
sleepless nights about yeah definitely
you know
i always over fought it and i was like
are people going to be supportive about
it because i didn't know you know it was
a bit of a shock but i did kind of know
that we are all a family and if you
don't support it then you're not a true
friend but everyone's been so supportive
so yeah it's been it's been amazing all
i can ask for has it impacted on your
behavior within the dressing room have
you found yourself withdrawing from from
conversations yeah a lot of the time so
there definitely has been conversations
where i've just been listening into just
what they what what they have been
saying just to know if it is the right
time to come out and if i'm going to
have that support behind me you've
signed your professional contract
you've scored 30 goals this season
you've made your first team debut in the
championship and now you've decided to
come out how do you reflect on the the
last 12 months because it's been quite
incredible yeah it's been a crazy year
you know everything has kind of happened
at once but it feels right came into
this year just like i need to smash it i
need to prove myself and you know i
think i have just off the top of that
you know i was like i'm having such a
good year this one last thing in my head
that's just been massive i just feel
like i do need to come out and
now it's out and people know i just feel
like i've done it you know it's live my
life how i want you now and it's been
amazing it's been incredible why do you
think there is this big taboo
in male professional football about
being gay
i think it comes down with a lot of
footballers want to be known as like
masculinity and i think
being gay a lot of people use it as
being weak so a lot of people would say
like you're doing that because you're
gay and they're gonna just say it's
because you're weak and it's just not
the case so a lot of people don't want
to do that because in football they are
masculine and it's something that you
can get picked on for on the field so
not a lot of people want to do it but i
think because no one's done it there's
just no one has the confidence to do it
yet so i want to be that role model to
do it to maybe push people to be able to
come out do you feel as though you can
inspire
others
to come out you're only 17 but clearly
you've got clarity in your mind
by coming out will other people look up
to you and and maybe feel as though they
can do it as well that's what i'm hoping
for anyway you know i think because i'm
younger people can think you know this
kid's brave enough to do this so i think
feel like i'll be able to and i just
want to do that for other people and i
want
maybe if there is premier league
footballers that are gay and are ready
to come out or they want to and they
just are waiting i want someone to
contact me and ask like how how's it
been what was the reaction like so i
want to help other people i just hate
knowing that people are in the same
situation that i'm in i think if a
premier league footballer does come out
you know that'll just be amazing you
know i feel like i've done done my job
and i've inspired someone else to do
that but yeah i just want
just want it to just go up from here you
know it we shouldn't be where we are
right now are you worried about
homophobia moving forward from fans
and on social media
you know i think it is an easy thing for
people to target you know i'm kind of
just learning that you know
like say i'm playing football on the
field and they're shouting stuff at me
you know you're paying to watch me play
football and i'm living my life and i'm
making money from it so shout out what
you want it's not going to make a
difference you know so i feel like i
can't stop people from saying that stuff
but i just need to learn for it not to
affect me can it make a difference for
fans as well because there will be
blackpool fans who are gay fans from
other clubs who are gay does this help
to make football more inclusive for
everyone yeah definitely you know people
live their lives how they want to so i
think you know it's going to be such a
massive thing there's many people out
there that are gay so just because i
play for blackpool don't mean that other
people can't support me and what would
your message be to
other people watching this who want to
come out
but have felt fearful of doing that
there's a lot of different aspects that
other people think
will scare them a lot especially in
football you know some people will
think that they're going to get targeted
a lot so you know it's in their mind
what they want but speak to people i
know it's such a hard thing so such a
hard thing for me to do was to speak to
people but if you are ready then just
speak to the closest people around you
and just
start off as a small group of telling
people and then if you do feel ready
just make it bigger and you are going to
get support